first of all I me Balan Robert and Lori
you guys are here to tell me all about a
game that you guys saw at PAX which I
know Kevin vinyl word loved at e3 a lot
of buzz around it at the moment tell me
what's so good about dreadnought Rob
what is so good about dreadknot is that
spaceship it's okay it's the slow-moving
spaceship that when you should when you
look at it the gameplay wise doesn't
look that fast pace but the cool thing
is is that there's actually so much to
do as far as managing your energy and
ship abilities and power by options that
it just really creates this high energy
high suspenseful kind of mobile field of
a map right it's weird because yeah like
you guys to come back saying this is
super fun to play kevin said at e3 it
was one of the best demos he's had it's
exactly to your point it's the type of
game that are over gameplay doesn't look
super exciting because it's so laborious
and slow and whatnot but you're saying
like the moment-to-moment action there's
like your kind of managing a lot while
even if the looks like there's not a lot
going on right right so there's like two
things that you're constantly doing as
far as control why so right here you see
your power abilities on top but the main
thing is you got this power management
where you're basically putting into
three things there's there's a example
there where am i imagining it and I'm
putting into shields what I know that my
health is going down time to throw on
the shields when I'm on a tack course
thrown into power up and down what are
your weapons so it's kind of like a
leash or self stuff like that but I
guess the big difference is that those
games are like dog fighting games right
yes dreadnought is a an online team
based game where you're you're not look
look how slow this thing's moving you're
quite a thing like we're really big
ships right really big ships and you
know if you're not into the slow moving
ones you get your kind of like quick and
nimble million Falcon then goes more
hidden run type stuff you know obviously
you've lower health so you get the idea
as you go in you go out and you're
constantly moving around and then here
you have your huge Jesus loking you know
dreadknots that have you know really
awesome like like this some of them have
like nukes we're like you fire a nuke
and then you can remote Dan
it and it just does like insane amount
of damage um but yeah there's just so
many cool abilities and you know I
sought a year ago and it was you know
it's fun but now they're doing these
things where it's like there's a new
Gretchen it just right oh yeah it just
didn't I'll it's you um so here's my
favorite so this guy right here oh man
and it was so cool and they did this so
this is a plasma ram so watch you yeah
throwing shields and then you gauge your
plasma ram right here and used ram these
dudes it's so freaking waste sites
that's like that's like you literally
ramming into people with that thing yeah
and it just like the smaller ships are
just they're done and then here's
another move coming up and I by the way
I had the devs next to me and they're
kind of guiding me and there's two these
guys yelling I me because you have to
line up the ship you have to charge it
up and someone will see it from a mile
away but here it goes boom oh god it's
you know they're slow-moving ships so
it's like there's such a suspense and an
amount of tension like trying to get to
a guy and using it is it like a pleasure
in knowing that that one shot like
Enterprise thought just killed about 500
education or whatever it was just like
immediately uh um so here's here's
another moment yeah there's a new guy
fire here and you remote detonate it but
then you get cool things to where you
know you say I'm I'm dying and I need
help so I talked my teammate I say I
need help they need help he can teleport
in as a power ability and then assist me
on the flip another guy it's a I'm
attacking a guy and he's about to
teleport cuz it's kind of a warm-up
period yeah I can throw down like a
disruptor ability to stop him from
warping cool um and so there's there's a
lot of management in your abilities ok
can I roll that back second you saying
is a medic ship yes there's a guy this
is a dead he's like I'm just gonna like
basically help you out right here so now
I'm warping to get closer to a guy
because he had lower hell oh whoa um
yeah there's a medic ship there's like a
sniper class you know those guys kind of
lurk around the sides and maps hmm um
sniper ships yeah this is weird because
this is so the last game I put like I
lovely dangerous in all of those games
but that what this is sort of
reminiscent of is is star wars
battlefront when I played that mode
where you were it was like thai fighter
vs x-wing basically yeah
where's the orgasm you know rubbers
versus the [ __ ] whatever [ __ ] star
wars and but that's like a dog fighting
simulator right so that's like you're
speeding around you're dying really
quickly a respawn and again very quickly
they've got kind of like they've got
loads of like creep almost which are
worth less points which are a I will
write on this kind of feels this looks a
lot more like something like World of
Tanks where you're working a totally
like a team your lives kind of matter
like what's the sort of turnover and
like time to die and how long are the
games what's the pace of it yeah they're
like you know Tom 10-minute games here's
actually this is a new game mode they
show it off um where it's like last man
standing but instead of spectating the
rest of the match you get to pilot these
really maneuverable you just keep
spawning these guys but the idea behind
this which is so cool is I die there's
say I got my like last teammate who was
actually flying around and my whole team
is are these low fighters you have to
communicate with these guys and take on
the other enemies in that you have
really you know low firepower but when
you all inter spite of you work together
and work together you can take other
guys down it's like via what was the
game where you respawn as a pigeon when
you died it was the it was armor right
it wasn't an armed line or something
they did that Andy what is it you like
about dreadknots question Daniel tete so
it's like five on five right yeah I've
been easy to jump in its got like Crysis
style like maximum armor maximum women
so it's really fast to select which is
awesome because you imagine if you're
actually at the helm of one of these
ships um talking about like elite
dangerous that's kind of like cumbersome
she like yeah where am I sit down my man
engines but I got a momentum it's like
oh I gotta like shoot but i got like
powered my weapons and wait and it's
like wait for the lock up a total of
manuals like a simulation yeah whereas
this takes all that's awesome about
piloting a ship like lasers and [ __ ]
rockets swarming everywhere and then
like plasma things and heels sure and
warping hmm and ramming and it's like it
puts it all immediately available to you
in a in a battle arena where there's
verdict out like you know you're not
just going at each other on a map you're
flying and maneuvering and you hang on
to recover
there's like little floating space
stations and [ __ ] like that speaking of
the sniper like you were you know that
was my favorite class yeah because I
would go like way far on the edges and
like go through these d'bries of like
asteroid mining facilities or whatever
there and just like take these really
long shots at these ships and they were
like did devastating damage but you know
I take like one shot I've been right
it's really cool to like balance that
out where you know you got all these
games like these first-person shooters
coming out like lawbreakers it's just an
ounce yeah overwatch gonna be great
battle born battle born this is like
that but its ships man you jump right in
but you're doing huge Battlestar
Galactica like era esque like ships I
know so it was kind of what you're
saying is their foolish easy to pick up
as opposed to like most space shootie
strategy games are kind of a little bit
cobras play around it's just like a
shooter but it's but it's spaceships
which is like that's pretty cool oh yeah
like World of Tanks you're saying that's
a good evening okay and it's another
free to play pc game which this is
they're not saying it's coming to
consoles yeah it probably is they
probably haven't got that self signed
yet and so i guess today and did it feel
free to play in that like the sort of
the hook with those games often is that
like they are very repeatable they're
very fun yeah you're kind of chasing a
carrot as well so are you unlocking
different chips you unlock in different
modes you mean lucky different like
aspects to your ships and write those
stuff so there are different classes of
ships the idea is that like if I focus
on one class I can kind of unlock other
ships but the another thing they showed
off which we couldn't show was now
you're able to take a ship and customize
the hell out of it so it's like a
control tower you know you see in like a
Star Destroyer screw that I want that
take it out choose like five options of
a another type of control tower like by
the end of it your ship looks completely
different and then that's not even
bringing like you paint jobs different
types of abilities like nukes you can
you know throw on and those have really
cool like lessons and stuff like that as
well yeah so that's where you going for
and that's what they said you know it's
not really clear whether that's like a
where the payment goes in but they said
it's going to be a very horizontal
progression as far as I'm walking cool
yeah well I guess final question I'm
kind of interested in this for a bunch
of reasons that one of them is that this
is being developed by Yeager who are the
folks who made spec ups the law
lion which is the type of there's no
white phosphorus no it's okay you know
like really civilian mini-game happening
a lot of know maybe yeah there they kind
of took third person shooters and they
made something very sort of unique I'm
not guessing is gonna be the narrative
through line that that game have and
read not but it did it stand it for any
other reasons is it just like does it
feel like a like a good balance between
simulation on arcade like what is the
sort of core thing that you really
enjoyed about playing dreadnought that
like made you want to come on and speak
volumes about it it just remember my few
Jase ship guy like I just anything that
has spaceships flying on sci-fi elements
I'm sold it's so sorry about what I said
about Star Wars it's alright but what is
so great about this game is you get so
much of that visually audio wise you
know just laying you know you know
broadsiding another ship and just like
all power like make it make a risk like
man my health is a little Oh screw it
I'm putting everything into power I'm
gonna take this guy out I'm gonna flee
it just feels very strategic in that way
and again I'm only playing by myself but
what I really got it was like man if
like I had some buddies with me who are
helping me out with some more sniping
talking to your other you nobody's is
gonna make this game really fun too yeah
because the ships aren't easy to kill
they're actually like they take a
beating especially if you're good at
managing there's a healer or your doing
your shields so you do have to like
focus fire and you the coordination is
cool because it's like an admiral taking
this fleet you know how like ship naval
combat in for example Black Flag is kind
of like really boring out yeah it was
like hold down thing shoot some cannons
and then they run away like and that can
happen in space games too right but this
it's more like a shooter it's like
totally Arkady but also like you feel
like you're accomplishing something that
took like naval flight academy style
yeah like the digit EG the kills are
satisfying reason cookie bunch at last
questions can you hear the explosions in
space see i was thinking the map i was
on was in atmosphere okay i could I saw
space levels could you hear explosions
Danny don't do this was it silent no
it's actually sound in space I heard
like your eyes are closed that's just a
sound and spice ever I was really
something he's just so different yeah
we'll see about that general thank you
so much for coming on and telling us all
about dreadnought